hey Chris waters here taking a look at
the new moon dance trailer for
Borderlands the pre-sequel in addition
to the wub wubs and poop jokes are
actually some interesting information
about the game in there so let's dig in
and see what it tells us kicks right off
with a character parade starting with
claptraps the frag trap a character you
can actually play as this time around
and then next up is handsome Jack notice
the distinct lack of freaky stretched
out face parts he's younger and maybe
less evil probably not then we've got
Wilhelm the enforcer who has a robo I
amongst other Robo parts the third vault
hunter Nisha the law bringer who Shops
at hot topic and looks like she could
duel wield weapons the fourth and final
ball hunter Athena the gladiator who
really doesn't like to be compared to
Captain America even though come on with
the shield thing it's it's just right
there and yes claptrap can actually hold
guns oh hey mad moxxi looking quite
mechanical here I mean I guess I makes
sense her kids scooter and Ellie are
both car geniuses they must have gotten
the knowledge from somewhere claptrap
mustache oh hey Lily the siren probably
not the only character from the first
Borderlands we're gonna see and for all
you made up word aficionados let's just
break this down bazillion DST r
bazillion dorost and Godzilla Godzilla
endear over three that kicks off a
combat montage starring these little
dudes who are either midgets in space
suits or little moon men straight out at
area 51 quick glimpse of the ice
elemental damage break in dudes apart
wait is that a brain paging dr. neck
couple variations on the new weapon type
lasers and a question where does this
ice meteor come from oh alright it's
just a grenade probably the ice damage
but it looked like it was a meteor okay
sweet argyle fashion disaster is Burt
gonna love this one actually before that
text pops in you get to see a few
tidbits about this gun that are
interesting you got your elemental
damage your melee damage bonus your
starship troopers joke would you like to
know more and an interesting little
attribute called moonshine that confers
a plus five percent chance
enemies dropping rare loot now this
looks like a relatively high level gun
but it makes you wonder if we won't be
seeing more diverse bonuses tacked onto
weapons in an effort to make the whole
operation more but zillion DONIC colt
whatever got one of those little Roswell
alien dudes riding a fiery moon scag
like he-man and battle cat over here and
something you can ride this flying new
motorcycle thingie called this stingray
para moon gowron's moon dinosaur moon
man not really a monster kind of
anticlimactic here ok now let's spend a
little time here there's a bunch of
skills on display for Athena the kinetic
ass piss at the top that's her shield
that can absorb frontal damage and then
the throne at enemies to deliver twice
the absorb damage it also looks like you
can boost a couple of the aspis
attributes like cooldown active duration
and defensive arc which determines the
area of damage absorption there's a
bunch of predictable buff to health and
damage etc many of which are fueled by
the aspis but there's a few interesting
ones like cruces which makes melee
attacks knockback enemies with explosive
force prismatic aegis which absorbs and
dishes out elemental damage clear just
by throwing the aspis you give any
downed allies in range a second wind and
you yourself get more damage in fight
for your life mode once you've activated
this CEO stalwart allows your friends to
blast the shield to charge it up with
damage so you can throw it back and do
extra damage and prepare for glory the
aspis throw acts as a taunt and baits
your enemies to attack you when they do
you get to stack of prepare for glory
whatever that is it's something that
increases your weapon damage while it
lasts and it slowly fades away after the
aspis comes back home to mama you also
get a look at Wilhelm the enforcers
skill tree his active skill is to summon
two automated drones called wolf and
Saint most of these are concerned with
wolf and Saint efficiency and duration
etc the interesting ones are the
cybernetic augmentation like power fist
which changes the melee to an explosive
punch with extended range and shock
absorbers which allows you to shoot
while sprinting and gain bonus damage
and have no accuracy penalties the cool
thing is you can actually see the
character model change
these skills are on lock boom robo arm
all this brings will hem closer to his
eventual I am a robot now state that we
encounter him in Borderlands 2 no word
though on how those robot upgrades
affects his dancing skills
Hey look a moon buggy and what appears
to be a drug store called dark siders
yes that's with an H not a k so we're
probably have to go on a quest titled
Special K for whoever the Walter White
Ian proprietor of that establishment is
right little Michael Bay circle strafe
pan around Nisha using a handgun the
size of her arm and also twirling a gun
in her other hand a dual wielding is few
shots of Athena looking totally bad a
claptrap manning the turret on this
buggy like a little foul-mouthed r2 unit
I'd say they've gone off the deep end
with these phrases but with jovial fear
pooping I think they've gone beyond the
deep end to whatever's beyond the deep
end this flying thing he has some pretty
nasty tooth work painted around the
cockpit nice touch there boss man it's
probably a boss there's something
quietly majestic about claptrap tracing
a gentle arc through the sky but here's
the weird thing with this shot look what
happens when his bullets hit the target
it's love we think like converting
enemies to fight for you maybe probably
that does not look like a dance kitten
october fourteenth release day at hall
ride that's cool it's not like there's
not a billion other games coming out in
October are you trying to kill us Chuck
in the ass piss at claptrap for some
reason jogging by a gross moon blob
tentacle alien thingy and the obligatory
finger gun to the head finisher Bridey
oh yeah Borderlands the pre-sequel
coming to pc xbox 360 and playstation 3
on october fourteenth be sure to let us
know anything you spotted in the trailer
in the comments below and come on back
to gamespot at noon on tuesday the first
day of III for a live demo of
Borderlands the pre-sequel I'll see you
there